face the nation moderator margaret
brennan joins us now good morning to you
margaret brennan
listen good morning to you gail yeah
late night for you
big night big big night for joe biden he
really painted a picture between
light and dark and the soul of america
and he says listen we have two choices
we will know i think
74 days if third time's a charm for joe
biden did he do what he needed to do in
that speech last night he sure is
getting rave reviews this morning
well he had no technical flubs no
missteps and
he did not look like sleepy joe the
moniker that the president has
put on him so he countered that it was
impassioned
it was empathetic and it really
delivered around some of those
points trying to relate to the american
people
eye to eye it was that head-on shot the
entire time
almost like a presidential address and
so
in some ways the biden campaign was able
to use this unconventional format
to his strengths which is to give some
empathy to
those who've lost family members and
loved ones during the pandemic for
example so
he did achieve those things whether it's
enough to persuade progressives that a
centrist democrat is their man too
or to get independents on board is
ultimately up to the voters
yeah he said decency is on the ballot
and decency matters to a lot of people
as you point out it was a very
unconventional convention instead of the
balloon drops
they come down they had fireworks that
bursted in air car horns to honk for
people in agreement
did the did the convention deliver and
work this time
well there were parts of it that were
awkward you know
the zoom meeting back to back over the
past few days but there were parts that
worked and i think
on the most important sort of
exclamation point to the week which was
joe biden's own
personal address to the country uh they
made the format work for him the same
way they did
for president former president obama the
day before
there weren't cheers there weren't booze
there was no one to react it was kind of
like a presidential address
in this hermetically sealed environment
so they made that work
for the candidate um but we'll have to
see what happens during the debates
uh we'll have to see what happens over
the 70 odd days
uh still ahead of us we just saw steve
bannon his arrest he's leaving court
really with the attitude of nothing to
see here but he is the sixth
close associate of the president to be
arrested what impact if any do you think
this will have on president trump
directly
sixth to be arrested second former
campaign chair to have some very serious
legal problems just this
week remember of course paul manafort
his former campaign chairman who's
already behind bars we learned this week
was accused by a bipartisan group
from the senate of being a grave
counterintelligence threat to the
country
that was a bipartisan finding from this
report this week so this definitely
draws some serious scrutiny around those
close to the president
past and current but it also in some
ways speaks to what joe biden is trying
to sell
as his main message which is that
content and character is what is on the
ballot
uh maybe you don't agree with his policy
initiatives but look he's a nice guy
uh and he has the character to restore
america's moral leadership if that's joe
biden's ultimate argument on the
campaign trail
these news headlines couldn't have been
scripted better to
serve that though clearly these were the
results of
years-long investigations so the facts
themselves have been quite damaging for
the president's campaign
we'll talk about some of that on sunday
all right to be continued